- [Voiceover] So we've been
talking about curvature.
And this means you've got
some sort of parametric curve,
you might think as parameterized by
a vector valued function S of t.
And curvature is supposed to measure
just how much this curve actually curves.
So here it's curving quite a
bit, curvature should be high.
But here it's, you know. relatively
straight so curvature should be low.
And I brought up in the last video
this pretty complicated formula.
And to remind you of the circumstances,
I was saying that curvature,
denoted with this little kappa,
is typically calculated as the
derivative of the unit
tangent vector function.
So we'll think of some kind of function
that gives unit tangent
vectors at every single point.
So you know, just a vector with
a length of one lying
tangent to the curve.
And that's going to be some kind
of function of the same parameter.
So big T for unit tangent
vector, little t for the
parameter, hopefully
that's not too confusing.
Then we're taking the derivative
of this, not with respect
to t, the parameter, but with
respect to arc length, s.
And by arc length, I mean
if you take a tiny step
along the curve, and consider
this to be of size ds,
so s typically denotes
length along a curve,
this will be a tiny change in length.
You're wondering how much that
unit tangent vector changes.
And specifically what I mean by that,
if you kind of imagine
tangent vectors off sitting in
their own space somewhere,
where each one of them has unit
lengths so they're all just
kind of of the same length
and lets say they're all
stemming from the same points.
So rather than drawing them
stemming from the curve,
to show that they're tangent, I just
want to show them in their own space.
The derivative, the change in
that tangent vector, would be
some, some other vector that
tells you how you move from one
to the other, kind of tells
you how much it's turning.
So the curvature itself is
given not by that vector,
because this would be a vector quantity,
but by the absolute value of it.
And I said in the last
video that it turns out
that this quantity, when you
work it out for a vector-value
function with components, with componenets
x of t, x of t and y of t,
that it happens to equal
this complicated formula.
And what I'm gonna do here,
I going to break it down
and show why this formula
isn't actually all that random.
It's actually kind of
sensible as a description
for how much the curve
really curves at a point.
So lets start by looking
at the numerator here.
This x-prime of t, first
derivative of the first component,
times the second derivative of
the second component, minus,
and then kind of symmetrically,
y-prime times x double-prime.
You might be able to recognize
this as a certain cross product.
So the cross product, if
we take x-prime, y-prime,
and these are still
functions of t, as a vector
crossed with the vector
containing the double primes.
And if you aren't familiar
with the cross products
or you're feeling a little shaky
and you kind of want to review,
now would be a good time pause the video,
take a look at the cross product videos,
and remind yourself both of how
to compute it and what the
underlying intuition is.
Because the way that we compute
a cross product like this is
you take the components in the
diagonal here, you know that
rightward diagonal, and
multiply them together.
That's where you get your
x-prime, y double-prime.
And then you subtract off
the components in the other
diagonal, you know it kind
of feels like a determinant.
X double-prime, times y-prime.
But the way that you
interpret this vector,
well I'll get to the
interpretation in just a moment.
First, first let me kind of write out
what this is in terms of our function S.
This first vector is just
the first derivative of S,
so that's S-prime of t,
the first derivative of S.
And we're crossing that with this one,
which is the second derivative,
vector value derivative,
but the second derivative of S.
So before we, before we
do anything else lets just
start to think about, what do
both of these vectors mean?
How do you interpret the
S-prime and the S double-prime?
I'm going to go ahead and give
ourselves a little bit of room here.
So I'll draw the curve again.
We're on our x, y plane, and
you have some kind of curve.
The function S itself is giving vectors
whose tips trace out this curve, right?
As T changes, the tips of these
vectors trace out the curve.
And now the first derivative,
that first derivative
vector, S-prime of t, is telling you
how that tip should move
to go along the curve.
As you go from one S
vector to another S vector,
what direction should that tip move.
And what this means is
that at every given point,
when you kind of do this
in a limiting fashion
and you only look at infinitesimal
changes in the original
vector, you always get some
kind of tangent vector, right?
So all of these are tangent
vectors, not necessarily unit,
you might have like a very
long tangent vector to indicate
that you're traveling very
quickly across that space.
And now, how would you think about
the second derivative vector
here, S double-prime of t?
Well the way to do
that, I like to think of
all of the tangents
vectors then just kind of
living in their own space, right?
If this here is representing
S of t, I just want to
look in isolation at what
S-prime of t looks like.
So each one of those
vectors, you know maybe this
first one is just is
very long, gargantuan,
indicating you're going very quickly.
And then after that you've
got something else here,
maybe it's pointing a little bit down.
And you're kind of thinking about how
all of these derivative vectors change,
but I want them all
rooted at the same point.
Just see what happens when
they're all rooted at the origin,
because that, that gives
us a way to think about
what changing the vector should look like.
So in particular, as you're moving from
this vector to this one, the tip should be
kind of moving in this direction, right?
So this second derivative
value is going to
tell us how the tip of the
first derivative should move.
And then similarly over here it tells us
how the tip of that should move.
And just as an example and
kind of a hint as to why this
has something to do with curvature,
if you have a curve
that turns very sharply,
turns very sharply, you would
have you know a tangent vector
that starts by pointing up
and to the right and then very
quickly is pointing down,
down and to the right.
So if they were off, you know
we'd kind of draw them on
their own, rooted in their own location,
you can maybe see how the
second derivative vector
is telling it to turn
somehow in that direction.
And if you, you know
capture not just those two
but infinitesimally what's
going on as you move from
one to the next you're gonna get
this kind of turning motion
for all of these guys.
So the second derivative
vector would be pulling
perpendicular, perpendicular to that
first derivative vector as
a way of telling it to turn.
So just to draw that on
its own, if you have a
first derivative vector, and
then the second derivative
vector is perpendicular to it,
it's telling it how it
should turn in some way.
But if it was, you know
lets say it was not purely
perpendicular but it was
also pointing against,
it would be telling that, that vector,
that first derivative vector,
to shrink in some way.
So that would be an indication that
not only is it turning
but it's getting smaller,
meaning the trajectory based
on S is probably slowing down.
And if it was kind of turning
it but also pointing away,
that would mean it's telling the
first derivative vector to grow.
So not only should you
be turning on your curve
but you should also be speeding up.
But the case we care about
most is we're just trying to
measure how perpendicular it is, right?
And this is where the
cross product comes in,
because if you think
about how you interpret
that cross product, how you
interpret the cross product,
it's basically the area
if you kind of take these
two vectors, tip-to-tail as
they are, and think about
the parallelogram that they trace out.
Lets see, so this blue dotted line
should be parallel to the blue vector.
The area of this, of this
traced out parallelogram
for each of them, that's what tells you
that's how you interpret
the cross product.
The cross product between
S-prime and S double-prime.
So this cross product, by giving
you that area, is kind of a
measure of just how perpendicular
these vectors are, right?
Because if one of them,
if they point very much in
the same direction, right,
and they're only slightly
perpendicular, that means that
the parallelogram they trace,
they trace out is gonna
have a very small area.
It's gonna be a smaller
area in comparison.
So with that, I don't want
this video to run too long,
so I'm gonna call it in
here, but then I'll just
continue on in the next
one through the same
line of reasoning to build
to our original formula.